-Welcome back.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-Last time, I got to say, you
were on our show, I loved it.
I also loved you brought
your dad.
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah, my dad's,
like, obsessed with you.
-Yeah, Leon is your dad.
-Yeah, definitely.
He's always like, "You know,
I just -- I love Jimmy.
He be having fun."
[ Laughter ]
"Him and -- you know, him and
the Roots and they is all --
they be having fun,
and Miley Cyrus comes on,
and they do all them
little impressions."
[ Laughter ]
He knows everything about, like,
Miley Cyrus and the impressions
and the Roots because of you.
-Yeah, there you go.
Well, thank you, Leon,
for watching. Hi, by the way.
Hi, Dad.
-Yeah, hi, Dad.
Hi, Papa.
-Your parents are always
supportive of you.
But you told me that you got
really a lot of
your comedy from Grandma.
-Yeah, totally.
I think, like, there's two types
of grandmas.
There's like
the milk and cookies,
"I'm going to knit you
a sweater" kind of grandma.
And then there's, like,
the drinks, swears,
wants to go to Atlantic City,
have a Colt 45 kind of grandma.
-Yeah, okay.
-And mine was the latter
and not the former at all.
-Really?
-Yeah, she liked, like --
She's no longer with us,
but she really liked
"Late Night."
Like, growing up, I would watch
"Saturday Night Live,"
"Mad TV" with her.
She loved Conan.
-With Grandma?
-Yeah, she loved like
"The Critic," "South Park."
Like, she just -- she had
a really good sense of humor.
-"South Park"?
-She loved "South Park," yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah, I remember she took me
to, like, opening night 'cause
she was so excited about
the "South Park" movie.
And I was really -- I was so
afraid of going because I knew
she was watching me
for the weekend.
And I remember, like,
the opening number
is just like a lot of
swear words.
And I was like, "Grandma."
She was like, "Yeah?"
And I was like, "I don't think
I can watch this.
I'm going to get in trouble."
And then she thought about it
for a second and she said,
"Why don't you take your little
butt outside then?"
[ Laughter ]
She was like, "I paid too much
for these tickets."
-"I'm staying."
-Yeah, she said, "I'm staying."
She told me to take my butt
outside.
And, so then, I was like,
"Well, what am I going to do?"
And so then, I just went to go
see, like,
"House on Haunted Hill" alone,
which also traumatized me
in, like, a very deep way.
-Yeah.
Probably worse than "South Park"
would ever do.
-Absolutely, yeah, totally.
-There's so much great stuff
happening for you.
I just want to say
congratulations.
It couldn't happen to a nicer,
more talented person.
-Thank you.
-It just got announced yesterday
that you're going to be in this
new series with Harrison Ford
and Jason Segel called
"Shrinking"?
-Yeah, I'm really excited, yeah.
-Pal, tell me about it.
How excited -- this is
Harrison Ford, I mean --
-Yeah. I mean, it's unreal.
Like, I was already,
like, really interested
because I'm a big fan of
Jason Segel and his work,
and a lot of the people
that are working on it
are, like, a lot of
the "Ted Lasso" people.
-Oh, that's right,
it's the "Ted Lasso" crew, yeah.
-Yeah, and it's over at Apple,
so I'm really excited about it.
-But have you ever met
Harrison Ford?
-No, of course not,
I haven't met Harrison Ford!
If I -- Jimmy, if I met
Harrison Ford, you would know.
I would rather, the next time
I see you, you introduce me
and say, "Jessica Williams
from 'Shrinking,'
has met Harrison Ford"
and then you bring me out.
And then we go like this.
-And then we do this together.
We make an offering,
yeah, of course.
You never -- I'm sorry.
Well, you're gonna love him.
-Oh, I'm excited.
-He's funny.
-Good, I'm glad.
-He's got a great sense of humor
and, yeah, you're gonna dig it.
-Yeah, I start next week.
So I'm really excited about it.
-Congratulations. I love that.
-Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-But let's talk
another great news.
"Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore."
This is giant.
Eddie Redmayne was here
last night.
-Did he do the manticore dance?
-What? Yes, we did.
-He's obsessed.
He's obsessed with
the manticore dance.
-Yeah, he showed me how to do
this really embarrassing dance.
He looks cool doing it.
I looked like an --
-You didn't look great?
-I looked like a comedian, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You joined the franchise
last movie.
-Yes, just a little --
I made a brief appearance
in the last one.
That was, like, years ago, so --
-Can you tell everyone
who you play?
-Yeah, I play
Professor Eulalie Hicks,
who is the Charms professor
at the North American
School of Ilvermorny,
which we have not seen.
And my character is brilliant.
She's really warm and witty.
And essentially, Dumbledore
recruits her to help
move against Grindelwald, who is
basically his bad ex-boyfriend
that you're just like, "Ugh,
come on, guys, get it together."
[ Laughter ]
We all have one.
And so, anyway, all this,
you know, she's really good
at defensive magic,
and she has these really cool
defensive magic sequences that
I'm really proud of
and that were, like,
the funnest to shoot, so --
-You are a "Harry Potter" fan
way before this.
-Yeah. Yeah, my teacher
started reading me
the "Harry Potter" books
when I was in the third grade.
-Me too.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I'm the same age
as you are.
-Absolutely.
Absolutely, fellow millennial.
-That's exactly right.
Yes, how cool.
Let's get on our skateboards
after this and skate around.
-Absolutely. And have
a hard time buying houses.
[ Laughter ]
-But to go into this world,
do you kind of freak out
being on set?
How much is real
and how much is CGI?
-I mean, obviously,
unfortunately the magic
is not real.
You know, but it felt like when
I was a kid and we would, like,
play fight growing up,
and, you know, you play with
an adult and you kind of do a
fake punch and then, you know,
like, my dad would go, "Aaaah,"
you know?
So we were doing that,
but we had these incredible
stunt people.
So I would kind of wave my wand
and things would happen.
But it was just like a guy
laying on the floor, you know,
shutting the door.
So, a lot of that stuff was --
-Still. It's movie magic though.
I do want to show a clip.
Here's Jessica Williams
in "Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore."
Take a look at this.
-I'll tell you what.
I'll give you the first shot.
-Go ahead.
-Are you sure?
[ Groans ] Oh, boy.
-Last time I ever help
that woman out again.
Lally?
-Whoopsie, Frank, sometimes
I forget my own strength.
I'll take it from here.
Thank you.
-Welcome.
-Catch ya later, darling.
-Bye, Stanley.
I'll be over for a game of
Befuddler Dudley soon.
-Alright.
-That's my cousin, Stanley.
He's a wizard.
-No.
-Please, it's early.
Don't make me work for it.
-I said I wanted out
and I want out.
-Come now, Mr. Kowalski.
-Can't believe my therapist said
you wizards don't exist.
[ Laughs ]
What a waste of money!
-You do know I'm a witch, right?
-That's exactly right.
Jessica Williams.
"Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore"
is in theaters and IMAX
April 15th.